the main target of terrorists is energy
therefore please be even more careful
than before about the need to
consciously consume electricity
we are trying to bring back lights to
people as soon as possible
I'm joined Now by retired Air Vice
Marshal Sean Bell who's been looking uh
in detail at the situation on the
grandchild great to see you as always
let's touch on these uh attacks on
energy facilities other infrastructure
facilities of the ukrainians is this
picking up pace it's been spread out
over the last week or so yeah the
Russian folks the last two weeks have
been energy infrastructure it seems to
be
um telling off a little bit but last
night there were another two major
attacks down to the south of Kiev and
there's been more attacks in context
more attacks in the last two weeks than
have been in the previous eight months
of the war which just demonstrates the
current Russian Focus to be clear these
are not military targets it does not
help further Putin's military war aim
it's all about terrorizing the local
population
and it does appear to be as much Putin
just lashing out doing what he can given
that he's not performing very well his
force is not performing very well on the
battlefields themselves let's touch on
Herson and of course that area where
Russia's ordered an evacuation what's
the latest on that Russian the Ukrainian
counter attack yeah the um cousin we've
got reports of the Russian military
heavy equipment now being moved across
the donipro river we'd expect that
normally to be a precursor for the
actual withdrawal of the Russian Force
themselves they'll be particularly
vulnerable as they cross the Junipero
River and therefore we can fully expect
to see Russia do some sort of
distraction something else to distract
their forces away the crossing points
the main Crossing points of the nupre
river
um the kakovka dam which is still
standing so that one's still standing
and then the antonovisky bridge which if
you recall was taken out by the
ukrainians very early in the war to try
and isolate the Russian forces the
Russians have been building pontoon
bridges next to that trying to get
across the Ukraine's I mean targeting
them then they rebuild them again they
they are standing at the moment and
we're fully expecting that um those that
they'll be critical Crossing points the
challenge I think here is that there's
also concerns the Russians of Mines the
dam up here and if they blow that it not
only flooded nepro River take out
Hurston very unlikely they do that but
before their withdrawal because
obviously that would trap them but it
would actually mask and cover their
withdrawal and stop their Retreat
becoming a route as we've discussed the
other day the trouble is with that if
you if you flood that area you not only
cause devastating consequences for the
southern part of Ukraine with fresh
water but also that's where the cooling
water comes from the zapparicha nuclear
facility and so that's all obviously in
the South take us to the East and what
fighting is going on there yeah we've
largely been focused a lot on Harrison
and I think it's worth pointing out that
up in the donbass well one area where
the Russians are still trying to push
forward is in the donbass in the Donetsk
region itself down the South here
um and the real question for me is why
if you remember the Russians the people
always have this special military
operation he talked about the Don mass
and the um Crimea as being his two focal
points well he's taken luhansk he hasn't
yet taken donetso fighting there and
more recently although he's lost a lot
of ground outside luhansk he hasn't lost
the ground here and the most recent
reports are the falconer group that
mercenary group a big busy doing some
massive great entrenching work here
building the defensive line all around
cremina and that's anti-tank traps and
trenches all the actions that you
wouldn't expect a Russian military force
that's on the offense be doing that this
is very very defensive and it does
appear to be consolidating the gains
made here making sure they repel any
further Ukrainian attacks and preparing
for the winter pause strumbell as always
thanks so much